holy smokes I'm sorry Apple you just got
killed is OnePlus finally back making
proper Flagship Killers well in this
video I have my iPhone 15 Pro Max and
the brand new OnePlus 12 and I'm going
to compare both of them in terms of
everything from the design the display
quality the brightness the performance
speakers and much more now on paper the
OnePlus 12 is incredibly impressive it
TR does look like a Flagship killer
phone especially with that insane 4500
nits of display brightness we'll put
that to the test see if it's actually
real but let's get this out of the box
right here we can see oh this is their
new really cool Green Design let's take
the sticker off that feels really nice
got this really cool texture and dang
look at that camera bump this is
absolutely crazy if we compare it to the
iPhone this thing looks absolutely nuts
especially with this massive circular
camera ring around it you got Hasselblad
right there you have the specs all
around and it looks like it has a fourth
camera but it looks like there's
actually just some sensors and the Flash
built in so this should be a pretty
similar camera layout now in terms of
the actual dimensions it looks like the
OnePlus is slightly narrower but taller
so the aspect ratio is a little bit
longer because it has that 6.82 in
display so it's kind of jumping the gun
compared to the iPhone 16 Pro that's
going to be coming next year with a
taller display and in terms of the
design we know that the iPhone has these
flat sides that are now a little bit
curved so it feels nicer in your hand
but I've got to say this OnePlus does
feel more comfy because it does have
this curved design all the way around
just all the way like this nice and
comfortable instead of like the new s24
Ultra which is picking up the iPhone's
design of flat sides of course we have
the leaks of the pixel 9 Pro also
becoming flat but but this is staying
true to the nice and comfy feel now on
the right side we have the volume
buttons the power button as usual like
we have on a lot of Androids but on the
other side we see just this one little
switch which is really nice that you
have this mute toggle physical switch
that we don't see anymore on the iPhones
or many other phones so this is a really
nice touch while of course we have the
new action button on the iPhone which I
love on the bottom we can see we still
have a SIM card trait on the OnePlus
which is really nice Apple got rid of it
a couple of years ago it sucks we don't
have it but I guess they're moving
forward we have USBC on both of them and
in terms of charging speed the nice
thing about the OnePlus is that you get
an 80 WT wire charger in the box which
is just nuts then they also have their
50 wat wireless charger which is
absolutely insane because Apple limits
it to 15 now you might might think that
probably decimates the battery health
but in reality Jerry rig everything
showed us that on the inside of this
OnePlus 12 they have two different
batteries stacked in tandem so it
actually keeps more cool and it doesn't
kill the battery health like you thought
it would so let's go ahead and power
this thing on and get it set up now
moving over to the front sides I can see
that the bezels on the OnePlus actually
do look thinner than on the iPhone
probably because it has a curved glass
display so the sides look super super
thin of course you have a whole punch
instead of the massive Dynamic Island on
the iPhone so basically it does look
more immersive and I also see that has a
razor thin speaker Grill at the top that
you could barely even see compared to
the one on the iPhone that is thin but
definitely more noticeable so with that
said the first thing I want to test is
the speakers because OnePlus has been
behind in terms of speaker
[Music]
quality all right wow that was really
impressive for the one flus because it
was actually a little bit louder than
the iPhone and it still sounded actually
really good the iPhone phone wasn't as
loud but I do tell that the the vocals
and the separation of the frequency is a
little bit better a little bit more
sharp and clear but I do got to give
props for OnePlus because this is a huge
Improvement now moving over to the
display quality the OnePlus 12 has a
1440p display which is really impressive
has 510 PPI compared to 460 on the
iPhone so the screen is actually more
sharp and better resolution and then on
top of that you can could do that
high-res and 120 htz at the same time
which is really nice while the iPhone of
course has the same 120hz promotion
technology that works great and now
let's get over to display brightness
where we have our first onp paper moment
because the iPhone has a typical manual
brightness of 1,000 nits compared to
1,600 on the OnePlus 12 but it looking
like this the I I's brighter clearly the
iPhone is brighter they're both set to
the maximum I even went into the
settings turned off auto brightness set
it to the full turned on high
performance mode I turned off everything
else that could possibly limit the
brightness and would you look at that
it's still dimmer than the iPhone it's
currently very overcast outside so we
just put both phones in front of our
studio light and still it's not bright
enough to make the max out but it's
still around the same on both now in
terms of HDR video brightness OnePlus
claimed that it went up to 4,500 nits
Peak but I'm watching this right now and
to me the iPhone is looking brighter
which iPhone claims it's 1,600 nits Peak
for HDR so I don't know what's going on
with the specs for the OnePlus but we're
trying everything we even tried to turn
off auto brightness manually set it to
the Max and still it's neck and neck
with the iPhone in terms of brightness
and in some scenes the iPhone is
actually a little bit brighter and a
really weird thing that I noticed is
that when you're holding the phone in
portrait mode like this with the actual
video being a small section it actually
is brighter compared to when you go full
screen you could actually see it dim
down a little bit almost like it can't
handle the brightness for the entire
display and now let's get into
performance starting with the SSD
storage disc speed test now I do want to
mention that both of these have 500 112
gigs of storage and that's a really big
deal because right now OnePlus is giving
you the 512 upgrade and 16 gig ram
upgrade for basically no extra cost $800
which is a killer deal because this
iPhone the 15 Pro Max with 512 only has
8 gigs of RAM and it cost me
$1,400 almost twice the price so if this
thing turns out to be really good it
truly is a Flagship killer now running
the speed test W look at that that was
really fast on the OnePlus 2600 mbes per
second read compared to 1,400 on the
iPhone and 1300 right compared to 1,400
right on the iPhone so slightly slower
right but very very fast reache and now
let's get into CPU performance with geek
bench 6 we have the new Snapdragon 8 gen
3 on the OnePlus 12 which is actually a
killer value for only
$800 this is actually the first one
we're getting with that chip compared to
the A7 Pro chip on the iPhone let's run
the CPU test and we got our results and
wow not bad Qualcomm looking at single
core the iPhone still has a lead about
32% faster but in
multicore it's only about 9% faster so
the Android side is starting to really
quickly catch up to what Apple's able to
do this is really impressive now let's
move over to the graphics side and we
know that qualcomm's 8 Gen 2 was
actually faster than Apple's for a while
and I think it might even be faster than
the new A7 Pro so this is going to be
interesting I'm going to run Wildlife
extreme unlimited and then a brand new
test which I'll show you in a minute
holy smokes I'm sorry Apple you just got
killed the OnePlus 12 with the
Snapdragon 8 gen 3
44.4% faster or higher FPS in Wildlife
extreme unlimited that is extremely
impressive I don't think this is ever
happened to Apple in I don't know over a
decade them getting destroyed in
graphics performance that badly Apple
you got to do something because this is
getting embarrassing right here we have
the brand new solar Bay test from 3D
Mark that's a ray tracing test which the
A7 pro has R tracing and the new
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 does as well so this
is going to be very interesting for rate
tracing gameplay all right let's run
this test and I have a feeling that this
might just end up being the best budget
Flagship of 2024 and wow there's an even
bigger difference looking at the overall
score the OnePlus is
55% faster or higher in terms of the
average frame rate that's extremely
impressive and this thing has insanely
good cooling so we could probably keep
it going for a longer amount of time
which I'm about to do the stress test in
just a second but take a look at this
looking at section three the FPS on the
OnePlus is 28 average compared to a huge
dip
15fps dip on the iPhone so it's almost
like it throttled down and had to cut
down the power much more than we had to
do on the OnePlus so this is just really
impressive so let's go ahead and do the
stress test to see how they handle the
power and heat over a long time I'm even
going to be checking The Thermals with
our seek thermal cam so let's get this
started the stress has been going on for
a while and I've already noticed that
the iPhone's display has dimmed down it
is no longer as high as it was matching
the OnePlus so so that signifies some
overheating so let's take a look at this
and wow 44° Celsius the hot spot on the
iPhone and it's all really close to that
spot where the chip is at whereas here
you can see just how much the heat
spreaders are spreading out the heat
across the phone and the hot spot is 42°
C so it's definitely staying more cool
and it's able to have the display
brightness higher so it's killing it in
terms of the consistency all right the
20 minute stress test is finished and we
can see that the iPhone is still dimmed
down because of heat you can actually
see right here I'm trying to raise it
brighter but it's not it's not reacting
because it's still overheated but anyway
getting to the results we can see that
the highest best Loop score is 8,500 on
the OnePlus 6,200 on the iPhone however
the stability is better on the iPhone so
that's basically how much it thermal
throttles because the OnePlus went from
8,500 down to 4,700 as the lowest Loop
compared to 6,200 down to basically
4,000 so this does hold the performance
a little bit better but overall the
OnePlus is still the winner here and now
let's get into the cameras first of all
I want to go through the quick specs the
iPhone has a 12 megapixel selfie cam
compared to 32 2 on the OnePlus 12 and
then on the back the iPhone has a wide
cam with 48 Maps compared to 50 on the
OnePlus the Periscope is actually 64
megapixels compared to only 12 with the
tetr prism on the iPhone and then the
ultra wide is also 48 megapixels on the
OnePlus compared to still 12 on the
iPhone and now getting into the actual
photo comparison itself I have a selfie
shot on on both of the phones and at
first glance they both look really good
so let's zoom in and see the detail and
even though it's 32 megapixel compared
to 12 they both do look really similar
although I do see a little bit more
sharpness on the OnePlus but honestly
I'm kind of liking the skin tones and
the Highlight rolloff better on the
iPhone just more of that warmth coming
through now moving on to a portrait shot
with the wide camera this is actually at
2X
on both of the phones and you can
instantly see a difference even at this
distance look at that orange kind of
sunset glow of our light bulb right
behind Max right there the colors are
really popping through compared to the
OnePlus where everything is just really
flat and the colors aren't really
showing up and then let's zoom in on Max
here and look at that difference the
iPhone is killing it in terms of the
quality you can see his facial hair is
more sharp you can see texture in his
skin whereas this is just kind of all
soft and blurry that's a win for the
iPhone again now here's where it gets
interesting because this is the ultra
wide which has 48 megapixels on the
OnePlus and I did shoot it in the high
resolution mode so let's go ahead zoom
in on Max and there you go now the
OnePlus is winning in terms of detail
just look at that look how soft and
grainy it is on the iPhone with that 12
megapixel quite a bit more detail on the
OnePlus but in terms of HDR I am seeing
a little bit more Shadow detail on the
iPhone down here with the couch and his
pants and shoes whereas this is quite a
bit darker and more crushed and then
let's move on to the main camera sensor
comparison we have 48 megapixels on the
iPhone 50 on the OnePlus and let's zoom
into this 1X photo and look at the
sensor detail and to be compl completely
honest the iPhone is doing better
because I can more clearly read all of
the names and text on this sign compared
to the OnePlus which is a lot more kind
of blurry and just more artifacts kind
of especially this sign in the back
can't even read it at all where it's
looking better on the iPhone and then
for this shot I wanted to do a 1x main
camera but in portrait mode because
Apple does have the 24 megapixel
portraits so let's take a look at how
much more detail you get and wow once
again so much more detail on the iPhone
you can see all the texture all the
creases in Max's jacket and his face his
hair zooming in a little bit more a lot
more detail on the iPhone you can
actually see the texture on his face
compared to all this just being really
flat with no Shadow detail and now we
have the Periscope camera the iPhone has
a new 5x compared to 3x Optical on the
OnePlus which I did shoot in highres
mode which is 64 megapixels and
apparently you can't zoom in which I
tried to do to match the kind of Zoom
length on the iPhone so we're going to
have to crop in in post like this on the
OnePlus and wow even with the extra
megapixels the iPhone 5x still looks
better with that Optical you can see the
details here there yep the iPhone is
winning here as well and now we have the
final shot which I've Zoomed In To the
Max on the iPhone which is
25x on that 5x lens and I did 25 as well
on the OnePlus which you can see it does
look better and that's because it has an
in sensor 6X crop which allows it to
apply all the algorithms and then it
zooms up to 25 so yes that does win in
this case so it seems like the only
thing that's holding the iPhone back is
the limitation of 12 megapixels for for
the telephoto and ultrawide which is
where the OnePlus won so with that said
we're actually also going to do an
unbiased blind camera test with the
OnePlus 12 against the regular iPhone 15
because the price points match up at 800
bucks so definitely subscribe for that
but let's finish off this video and
answer the original question is the
OnePlus 12 a Flagship killer that
destroys the iPhone 15 Pro Max at a much
lower price well almost because a lot of
the things are really good like the
performance especially but a lot of the
specs on paper are just not showing up
in real life like the display brightness
it's just nowhere near what they
advertise and the camera even though the
specs are great it's not as good as the
iPhone in most cases so I would say no
it does not defeat the 15 Pro Max but
for an $800 price especially for 512
gigs of storage and 16 gigs of RAM this
is probably the best Android phone that
you can buy and maybe even the best
budget phone and maybe even the best
budget Flagship of
2024 so hopefully you enjoy this video
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and subscribe
above for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video